this morning we're looking at
understanding huntington's disease one
local woman is making it her mission to
spread awareness surrounding the disease
and support for those who are dealing
with it sarah gardner's father passed
away from huntington's disease in 2015
but her battle surrounding the disease
continues huntington's disease is a
genetic disorder progressively breaking
down the nerve cells in the brain it
impacts a person's physical and mental
abilities after her dad raymond's
diagnosis sarah and her mom would turn
to local support groups to learn more
about huntington's and its symptoms
which include slurred speech involuntary
movements and so much more her dad's
symptoms even led to him being wrongly
arrested as police thought raymond was
intoxicated in public
it was a shock for sure and i said what
are you doing why are you in jail and he
said i don't know
i don't know why i'm here and
i said well what did they arrest you for
and he said public intoxication
and i was like there's no way like my
dad would never do that like it was just
totally not in his character
sarah says while she tested negative for
the disease she's still active in the
huntington's community and hopes
spreading awareness will help others in
similar situations heather